you will never escape my hogs
[Music]
people keep making fun of me my
tambourine
is not big enough they say yeah
well i'll prove you i'll prove you all
once and for all
i'm gonna have the biggest tambourine
ever seen
it's gonna reach the moon okay
yes 10 inch all right how many do they
sell
30 add to basket oh
well 30 is not going to do it i need
more tambourines
more tambourines i'll buy out your whole
goddamn stock
50 at the basket proceed to check out
oh god why does this hurt
this hurts me so much you know what i
don't care
buy now what's that that's face delivery
i said don't look in the boxes
you see this do you know what's inside
take a guess hammering
how many tamarinds this costs more than
your engagement
[Music]
i'm so excited we're going to the moon
do you know what we're doing
tambourine tower
hammering power to the moon to the moon
whoa oh they're all individually wrapped
that's annoying
all right if mr beast can have a pool
filled with tambourine
oh why are they all individually wrapped
that's so annoying
all right follow me oh sorry
oh some fell out what are you doing
it's really 50. that's not 50 tamarinds
are you serious i've been vegeta
this is here 28 and well 28 in each the
other one is 28 too
i got more than 50. but did i is that 25
i didn't look like 25 tambourines i
don't [ __ ] around with tambourines
eight tamarind salesmen
youtube that's not a that's a joke
that's a joke
tambourine salesman this is your peepee
snip snip
oh oh yeah there's more in this one
never mind we're good we're good
we home is tambourine sales man
that's a lot of tambourines all right
might say can you this
is that okay can you do that i just
gotta gotta play minecraft
mm-hmm guys can you wanna help out here
come on no no
no you don't think all right well
time lapse coming right up epic
tambourine unboxing timelapse
[Music]
i kind of wish i had like an assistant
edgar excuse me
what do you mean how what
yeah you're helping me i appreciate it
everyone thank you to martin sanders
i am getting more efficient though
i kind of like excuse me i'm the star
don't ever film them
i kind of like uh me menial tasks i feel
like i should work for mysteries
just like you want me to unbox 500
cameras
i'll do it i'll do it i don't care i'll
do it
sorry give up i feel like i'm going
crazy
how did i do this this is abandoning me
this is a bad idea
where are you going come back here i
need you to help me look at this man
by the way in case you're wondering we
are going to rese
we are going to recycle all the
tambourines
they'll be given to feed the homeless so
it's all good
look how fast sam okay let me
look how fast i am
well i was so lucky there usually way
more quicker done
next one if i was a speed runner
tambourine unboxer i'd get world record
done we have peace
i feel like there should be more
tambourines do you feel like it should
be
you're saying yes yeah people can't hear
you it's not your head yeah
yeah yes
you're not impressed by the amount of
tamarind
did i get swindled by the tamarind
salmon i'm gonna count them
if there's not at least 50 tambourines
sorry i have 50. i think it will be okay
[Applause]
they're five centimeters uh in
size what what was so funny about that
tonight
five centimeters in there hi
i thought you're making fun of me so
that means
according to my math if you put all 50
together
it'll be two meters and a half roughly
right it's the moon at that height or
yeah
yes it is this is the start this is the
start of the way to the moon
i got the ladder how tall is the ceiling
it's gonna be way taller like three
three four meters at least five i think
it's 350.
if the curtains are three meters okay
how the hell how does that make any
sense you know i feel like i'm kind of a
cardboard expert as a youtuber you get
sent so many packages that i spent half
my days just like
recycling cardboard anyway it's a life
it's a life to live this is what i'm
doing hey
marcel you know that meme where
the guy looks like he's totally beaten
up and then there's like a someone on
the side saying something
martial going phoenix unbox my 500
makeup package
and then i go yes queen i will recycle
i should jump from there into the
tambourine that's a good idea
besides please zoom every time he swings
the knife
like what every time you have a knife
[Music]
yeah threatening my wife
i wonder what they thought when they got
the order
maybe they're like oh that's so cute
they're gonna have like a little
tambourine parade or something
maybe they thought it was for like a
school
yeah oh look little kids they're ugly
hammering
no screw you kids
i'm building a henry tower
to the moon nasa is going to be like bro
how do you do that
there's no tape on this one that's so
nice
save me time i'm going to pause okay
why can i
is about to cut guys can you believe
that unbelievable
we're almost done i was literally on my
last one
that's a pivot pivotal moment if
anything you should sign
up the music up the anthix all right
here we go guys
this is the last tambourine slow motion
please
what can't hear you over the epic music
all right here comes
don't look at me cut
57 marines that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
i gotta be the most annoying neighbor of
all time
[Applause]
[Music]
come on brother come on brother hit the
tambourine
damn it
you're coward you're fooled and you're
not my
son let's start with 10 pep rings and no
my my saying onto your head i call you
my first things
saying
i can't do this 50 times that's going to
take
50 years i'm switching to glue
this video is sponsored by glue glue
gang hey if you're glue gang instead of
tape gang
hit me up in the comments tape gang of
blue glue gang wanna say it
pick okay
you know i was born in the glue molded
by it'll take a lot longer
that's because you're a tape gang
oh did you open the cupboard right there
yep
you like this
[Music]
yes that's fine
see that again now we're going to do
that ten times
we're not we're not vlogging anymore
we're good man what you use
tape wrench
don't take it you take okay paper glue
answer
how long does it take to one to two
hours
what did i say i'm taping
taping no it's all right it's all right
sorry i guess what we learned here today
is that tape and glue
has many different purposes there's pros
and cons
and there's totally valid to like either
if you're taking that's okay
but if you glue gang your mother oh god
oh god i shouldn't have done that what
why did you not told me i had to wait
two hours ah
it's sliding out it's like a sliding
thing oh no can you eat it
[Music]
promote it i'm tempted
i didn't taste anything don't eat bloody
kids so
uh i borrowed the ladder from our
neighbor
he thinks we're going to put up curtains
which we are we are going to do
but we're also doing this so how was
your day my mom
sound i will give that doesn't look as
good even if it's clear
oh god it's why are you serious this is
the slowest
glue i have ever seen why do i oh
they kind of like nice
that's a good one i like that look how
are you nice
my name is felix schelberg born 1989
october 24th
i am about to attempt the world record
or fastest tambourine tape
three two one
what was it what was the record what was
the time what was the time what was the
time
they were all we're already out of this
one and i only bought two
what i have more you have more tape yeah
montia
you're true to the tape gang i respect
it at least you're a lawyer
get yourself a wife that's loyal
you know what i'm saying i'm a little
tired but it has to be done someone had
to do it
someone gotta do it don't let it do it
who's gotta do it
someone gotta do it
we have glue gang or we have tape gang
but we haven't tried drill gang
drill game where my drill gangers out
has anyone drilled a tambourine before
we about to find out can i drill a
tambourine
wait it's not
[Music]
it's hard to penetrate a tambourine man
am i gonna drill it first
you know what let's just do it from the
middle
[Music]
all right is it gonna hold or not
comment down below
what do you think
all right drill game you can't win the
mall drill game
this is quite artsy it smells like an rp
piece like that
does that make you feel anything nope
all right i guess some people don't
appreciate our this is the moment before
it's all gone i know that's when people
click
out or they click they click forward yes
they're like oh yeah i get to just sit
there she's building tambourines
but keep watching because you never know
what's gonna happen we might give away
an amazon gift card
oh no no no no
it's it's getting undone
if you were an instrument which
instrument would you be
violent violent they're so annoying it's
literally screeching it
you can't be a violin actually it fits
you well get it huh
no you'd be a maracas
what if you say so you don't want to be
maracas harmonica you're a harmonica
oh you know what i will beat oh my god
next video guys we're going to get 50
whatever those are called for marxian
all right
thank you smash like if you want to see
that happen
all right i'm just going to wrap up the
last one we'll see you guys at the grind
for now
last one baby i ran out of tape i'm
using
paper tape but i found a technique that
works and then
god damn it all right this is what
insanity looks like
boom oh oh god all right
look look the glue kind of like oh it's
still sticky but it
kind of bubbled up a bit can you tell so
it's almost like
it's pretty good now it's not perfect
but it's pretty good
glue gang ain't so bad after all i could
have saved a lot of time doing this
yeah yeah yeah
you wanna play again here i'll let you
be the first one
play
[Music]
let's put them all together you know
tape is made out of glue anyway so it's
going to be tall
you can tell now are you excited
yeah have you ever seen anything like
nope
[Music]
i feel a little dizzy oh god i got three
more
damn i'm actually glad i got a ladder
now thank you neighbor
shout out to the new ass sukida market
let's go this is pee pee size
don't make that face to me you love me
remember
so i play some like royal kind of
fanfare music okay then put a king
and a cape on me king kron because this
is some king
are you ready i can hear people chilling
outside are you watching
thumbnail oh
god that's a lot less unstable than i
thought
how high do you think that is 250. no
i'm 350. it's gotta be at least six
meters at least
someone might die if this falls think
about that
it's done just kidding
it's not done these are 52 tambourines
52 tambourines you may wonder why
i got 52 well you see
you could oh sorry 62 62.
you may wonder why you would get 62 10
well that's because if you add 7
tambourines why i need some timing
don't worry about the details what
number do you listen to
62 plus seven oh wow
say it out loud say it
say the number of tambourines
what 69. 69. you know why i picked 69.
i won then because of the moon landing
we're going to the moon
okay 1969.
what were you thinking this last tape
is in your honor thank you we're doing
the
outside technique that italians have
done since the ancient romans
that is stable yes i
got it i'm so happy yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
keep adding tamper rings we're gonna
fill it to the moon to the moon baby
throw them all down
[Music]
i could die if i fall from it should i
step on should i not step on it or step
on it what did you say do not
no this is my height anyway it doesn't
make a difference
i'll step on it okay i'll step on it
what are you gonna do stop me
you're gonna stop please stop i'm not
gonna
all right i'm gonna do that you know
what a party pooper we got here
[Music]
like subscribe next time we're doing 69
maracas
what the hell is still my glory
oh that does not work so heavy
and you better take dude i gotta
i gotta lift it from like here
oh no [ __ ] your shitty tape doesn't work
oh god it's fine
it's fine
okay everything's
[Music]
tambourines
play with instruments they're not poised
ah
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
creatures fart spells and poop troops
awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo swag
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]